thank you
thank you so much you got to take a hit
off of this and just pass it around this
is Jack's personal Oscar buzz so I
wanted to thank you for giving me this
good evening everybody I'm delighted to
be here I'm Billy Crystal I'll be your
master and commanded tonight and
and well into tomorrow so let's get
going gentlemen start your egos
yes
wonderful night Ross asked Ross who will
win
yes here we are the 76th Oscars and he's
still gold his hip is titanium but he's
still gold tonight will beam broadcast
in 53 languages and that's just for Los
Angeles alone and for the very very
first time we're being simulcast in
Aramaic
we have wonderful stories tonight a lot
of first-time nominees I want you all to
know well your first time is it is
customary to tip the host first-timers
Shelly's the run man Charlie's miss
Theron you look absolutely beautiful but
in that movie you scared the bejesus out
of Mel Gibson I can't believe that you
was that scary in that person look at
this this is not possible Mel Gibson's
movie unbelievable hit 117 million
dollars open on Ash Wednesday had a good
Friday a better Saturday and Sunday
unbelievable another first-timer Keisha
Castle Hughes just 13 years old there
you are
13 you're too young to have three names
I first hosted the show 13 years ago
things were so different then you know
different it was Bush was president the
economy was tanking and we just finished
a war with Iraq isn't that amazing
unbelievable 13 years ago there's Johnny
Depp the sexiest man alive
did I just say that out loud of course
Johnny's nominated for playing Jack
Valente's worst nightmare a slightly gay
pirate this was a year of great small
movies like City of God an American
Splendor now we had the big guy
Seabiscuit and Lord of the Rings with 11
nominations yes
11 11 nominations one for each ending
and let me tell you something else for
then of course this Mystic River movie
about grief murder rage or Sean Penn
calls it a light-hearted feel-good romp
Mystic River that missed it
as dark and murky as mom's chopped liver
Mystic River it just keeps rolling along
there's our shooting and there's of
eating it's like a Disney and Eisner
meeting but old man Eastwood it just
keeps rolling along
all Clint
you've made hits you don't make slop you
perform with monkeys and Sondra Locke do
you produce you write the score you sang
and paint your wagon please don't sing
we add Leary texting of try and most men
your age arrive the dead or dying but
not ladies would you just keep rolling
hi Tim Iceland good to see you
hello look at this everybody from
Hollywood is here wait this is like the
Canadian Oscars
another great movement is here was lost
in translation this is yes a lovely
movie this is governor Schwarzenegger's
favorite film
directed by Sofia Coppola the first
American woman ever nominated for Best
Director
she made this movie in 27 days took
Francis that long to wake up Brando
and he welcome up with three little
words key lime pie
three nominations and she's being very
humble about it saying it's just great
to be nominated but I don't think that's
true
you gotta date Peter Jackson woke up
with seed biscuits head in his bed
Sophie huh I just sort of film hi Sophie
the credits made me cheer Scarlett
Johansson's rear Thank You Sophia I just
love that film by Sophie ha
Bill Murray showed us rain to hell with
all these a toast Oh Sophia now you're
here and your Oscar finery while your
dad stop and grapes at the winery Sophia
yes Hosler may call out Sophie Julie
Andrews I apologize in advance
hobbits with feet big and hairy and
smelly more epic battles than guests in
Minnelli he Anand Viggo with Queen and
some kings this is the gang and the Lord
of the Rings Frodo and Sam on a mystical
planet than Smeagol pops out like the
right boob of Janet Britney and JMO
brought both of their flings they
thought it was called the return of the
Rings
lithium sake some pills and peyote
moonshinin ritalin from truman capote
j.r.r tolkien was taking these things
who when he conceived of the Lord of the
Rings Peter Jackson made his trio he
sure got it right I loved every frame
with a lot of the Rings so I downloaded
last night
see biscuits
he's of course the horse Oscar may go to
or else she's glue
got nice brisket Willie win Oh will he
lose by unknown
let's ask Pete roll
course only know
Oh hero
the watch is no wylie grow all the
bookies y'all
my just got off his toe
oh boy
you gotta have a little prick Sal with
me the boat is a Russell Crowe
it's his damn ship so don't give him lip
or he'll punch you in the nose his
master and commander Darcy bloom once he
got me out there on the far side of the
world
samms unfurl I just curled he may get
you out there when a war in solve the
French and there ain't no wedge but
don't cry boys next Fort San Francisco
hey Oscar man is time to start the game
Djimon Hounsou showed up on - luo they
can run out your name get a 1cu we
choose to cheer these best male licks
and so shut off your damn cell phones
bring out the drum and big taco was
Austin
hey r7e
Rabbitohs up was opposite oh yeah
you